This program is a presentation of UCTV for
educational and non-commercial use only.
When James Parkinson's originally
described Parkinson's disease it was
thought just to be a movement disorder.
This is a disease
that needs to be recognized early because there are treatments that might affect
the natural history and may slow down the
course of the disease.
Yeah I wasn't very happy about being
diagnosed. I felt like I was young,
I felt like I was healthy, I felt like I
took care of myself.
I saw my orthopedic surgeon because I was feeling a lot of pain in my leg.
and he pretty much told me it was all in my
head. I think it's important to
understand what Parkinson's is.
It is a chronic disease but it's one
that you can live with
and you could have a long and fulfilling
life with it.  You know when you're sick,
usually you get better?
I thought, well you know, okay so this
is a problem, but you know it'll probably get
better -  which is of course
totally wrong. All the treatments we have right now deal with symptoms.
They're basically bandaids for the
disease. They don't address the
underlying disease which just keeps
getting worse,
anyway. You know I feel like I can
accommodate whatever comes along
you ready to my minuses soul
that'll
a person out with a break the bicycles
but what about my body it the
life expectancy is almost the same as
for people who don't have
Artist Series typically patients do not
die
from Parkinson's disease they die with
Parkinson's disease
some interest in my bed just pull the
covers over my head going to do this the
interstate
and I'm but that doesn't happen very
often
and
the next a cap and joy comes in the
morning and
and the darkness is over and I face
another day
with mishandling see you do this many
people don't understand what parkinson's
disease is
follow it with you parkinson's disease
is the accounts have a group of symptoms
and signs
that together constitute parkinsonism in
the absence of any
obvious unknown cause without evidence a
more widespread disease
parkinson's disease is a characteristic
clinical disorder
a notable for three major symptoms
a one is a tremor which is often the
first one that appears very
characteristic tremor
another is Brady can usually which is
slowness of movement
and the last is rigidity or stiffness
and those are the characteristic
features and its
it's not just those three symptoms it's
the way in which they begin
it's the way that they progress it's a
%uh it too
it's a larger picture which is
recognizable by many clinical trials
as idiopathic Parkinson's disease with
your right hand can you this big and
fast with the pointer
damages keep going it is due to a loss
love a number nerve transmitters
including dopamine
dopamine it was pretty is in the cells
with the generate an
in this region close attention i grandi
brain is one of those chemicals that its
required to keep those wires connected
is also worth to
mation is a progressive disease that
patients usually develop a very mild
form of the disease that
gets worse and worse with time is more
is more the cells
the generated after out timers disease
this is the second most common
you a degenerative disease that too is
in probably in the United States
at this time there are more than a
million people affected
it's a disease that occurs little bit
more commonly in men than women
it occurs with advancing age and it
leads to increasing disability
unless patients have treated and even
then there may be some limitation
had to get a new hobby a political ally
I read more
I get involved in politics in a way if
carville it look at other things that
are important in life
and ever more appreciation for things it
is a everyone I know has Parkinson's has
a dog and I just think that
they keep you going and move a min at
they don't care that African said I'm
pastor a church in San Francisco the
decision to tell my congregation was
very difficult it has been a tremendous
challenge to faith
because I thought I had it all figured
out
don't worry about it and try and just
lead your life to the fullest possible
extent
cool as training for a marathon and
my legs are cramping up and I had
just dolls with the trouble running
where had been Prime three or four
months power
and had successfully run the New York
Marathon parkinson's disease is a highly
variable disease
we see patients who had Parkinson's
disease for thirty and forty years after
diagnosis
are some our stock walking into the
clinic in other patients
I have greater disability the only
sometimes I really have
other series at the moment is currently
have them sometimes the term
for the fact is that most patients are
very individualistic
and the progression of the disease can
be completely different
parkinson's effects the right side of my
body and side I get
but it hasn't progressed much in the
past five years when patients initially
come and they usually have had symptoms
from one to two years prior to coming
into the evaluation
so usually they're complaining have some
big symptoms
they're not necessarily completely
indicative the Parkinson's disease
so you want to do it a sterile
neurological evaluation to make sure
that what you're looking at
really truly is parkinson's disease fold
your arms and you arms folded stand-up
great unfold throughout happiness walk
down the cartel
good night he turned around
well I was dragging my at legal a break
I was limping a little bit I noticed
in mind and and I'm tremors
finely when my wife thought one day we
went to the
internist right away said I think if
parkinson's
I said there's this I'm healthy and
nobody in my family is ever had
Parkinson's I couldn't be
it should be noted that bad about 30
percent of patients
who come in and get diagnosed do not
have a tremor
mainly I was holding my arm and
happened you the my hand never had any
trouble
it is a complex interplay I've have
symptoms and
findings might be on greater clumsiness
with a hand
or an irregular footstep that develops
overtime could you make a spiral like
that
and 75 percent in people there is often
a tremor
that develops that maybe intermittent
and is usually most apparent when the
hand is in the lap
or suspended 11 is walking might
people exist to freeze took me awhile to
2 I'm phrase ice to fall backward
seeks 7
eight times a day constantly a kid
for Windows boy who's this I'm gonna
push you back would like this
I want you to resist me alright I won't
let you fall
who any go
the in Iraq well done
I promise you I catch you thank goodness
I did some individuals with Parkinson's
will experience some type of causing the
problem
over the course of their illness
typically at the time of diagnosis this
tends to be relatively mild
been made just involve slate attention
difficulties
perhaps difficulties with multitasking
doing more than one thing at a time one
of the things have noticed
visit I can't divide my attention when
I'm doing something
me the walking prime talking about 30
percent of people with Parkinson's
disease
again to develop a significant
impairment of cognitive function
that commonly thats late in the course
of the disease
sleep disturbances are quite common in
Parkinson's disease
and fairly commonly patients or their
families become aware that their speech
is somewhat softer
depression and anxiety maybe
the most disabling symptoms they
definitely
have bad days and more days then
parkinson's it goes with depression and
that's where the same today
keep my eye on an I know my doctor keeps
his eye on for me
for one other things the doctor and I've
told me I'm
that I really appreciate it heat said
that if you
research all things that might happen
you can anticipate it in the brain is a
funny thing in that sometimes you might
anticipate something that's not actually
there
because I don't know when something's
knew I have to ask him
is this what's supposed to happen is
this normal
you know the feeling go
somebody polling cold
I so what they're on your hand that the
feeling
it was hot too to accept it and in the
beginning I D nev.
sets if the other at symptoms that they
are
you know really into feel good night
everyday life
positions often have as much difficulty
as diagnosing parkinson's disease as
patients families do in recognizing that
something actually is wrong
other than simply the advance a fifty
years I was at my
GP for me annual physical when he asked
me what this
shaking my going on what was that all
about and I
frankly didn't know so he sent me off to
a neurologist who
gave me the diagnosis in it was
kinda hard for me to to accept that that
mean
and I didn't for well I think I'm my
continued on justice
ignoring the fact that I had until
certain things became or more for a
problem
many patients want to come and see us
because they
I'm I they have uncertainties about the
diagnosis
I or want a second opinion and that
really is
an important world and I believe we play
I think I had an inkling that things
were coming
remember one time in particular I was
was very upset
at work my whole body started shaking I
out on its pretty weird I so my
orthopedic surgeon because it's really
not a pain in my leg
and he pretty much from is on my head
and it wasn't until I had a little
tremor
in my hand which I thought was low blood
sugar that a
the hand after for between our largest
letter that Christine
Anna he did a for as a test in these
that I think you know I'm a gonna say
and I was like but on my head and it
wasn't on my head it was
parkinson's the diagnosis a parkinson's
disease is a clinical diagnosis
there's no pass that can say you do you
do not have parkinson's disease
Parliament down slowly king following it
I think it's important
that primary care doctors undertake a
general neurological examination to
exclude an underlying
neurological cause for the patience
sometimes
I've remember and I'm waking in the
middle of the night night
I thought this has all been a dream and
I stayed awake for several hours
thinking and praying and then remembered
I think that
it started to hit me and I cried and I'm
at that moment everything seems to be
darkest
you know because it's unknown I was
Creed sometimes it is difficult for the
patient themself
to really acknowledge what's going on in
part of that
maybe because there are certain changes
in the brain which make it difficult for
people to fully appreciate
their own symptoms over the
time I just but become
accepting the fact that that's who I am
and this is where I'm I am in my life
and I'm you know I'm disappointed it
sank into some things I would really
like to do but
me off I'm other things you know bases a
lot left
got a lot of time left in my life
we have identified a series of jeans
which we now know
to cause Parkinson's disease well we
know
that one or the other genes that's been
implicated in Parkinson's disease
that gene product called alpha-synuclein
accumulates in the brain basically
everybody with Parkinson's this simply
making more of this protein moreover the
normal alpha-synuclein protein
is sufficient to cause Parkinson's
disease
many of us believe that the cause of
parkinson's disease
late space to a genetic susceptibility
and also perhaps
exposure to some toxin no other in the
environment
there are basically two hypotheses that
we've had over the years about the
pathogenesis a parkinson's disease
one actually concerns dopamine itself
it's the dopamine neurons which
degenerating parkinson's disease which
disappear and as a result patients have
a dopamine deficiency
but at the same time we know the
dopamine is actually a pretty toxic
compound
it's a normal neurotransmitter all over
brains but it's actually quite toxic
and for most people that don't get the
disease they can handle the toxin
but for people with Parkinson's disease
they can't handle the talks to me more
and the dopamine itself
ends up killing the cells that make it
which results in
a dopamine deficiency the other factor
is this protein alpha-synuclein
and we know that this protein
alpha-synuclein doesn't just accumulate
and kill dopamine neurons it accumulates
in many
other neurons in the nervous system and
that accounts for probably a lot of the
cognitive problems
and other problems that Parkinson's
patients get and so the idea is that if
the new clean goes up
it's going to force the ball before it
kills cells
impair all kinds of neural circuits and
the behaviour your brain as a whole
before you ever lost any neurons and
that it basically starts as a functional
disturbance
which eventually results in the death of
some cells
such as dopamine neurons in this
actually changes the way we think about
Parkinson's disease
and so we think this gives a great
inside and a a way to
intervene in the disease before that has
progressed very far
such as they would come up stay up from
is anything to happen iraq's
yeah me show you didn't okay
the real challenge now is not just to
find treatment for the symptoms
but to try and treatment for the
underlying disease
so we really need understand that
underlying problem for we can do
something about
the medical treatment primarily is with
medications
that treat the symptoms so they don't
treat the underlying disorder
it may be that some medications actually
slow the progression of the disease
I'm on something called as a like that
are
is supposed to delay the the progression
of the disease
but it also iPhone
has alleviated some symptoms typically
overtime patients may start to respond
less well to medication because the
disease is advanced
vulnerability heard the phenomenal
8 cinema peeled 5
company and playing a quick
everyday treatment has been named at
replacing the dopamine that is deficient
in Parkinson's disease
and one can do that in two ways one can
give what's called a dopamine agonist
that's a drug that acts like to help me
but actually isn't
all one can give the precursor dopamine
that the body then converted to dopamine
and that's the drug called leave a doper
probably the most effective drug
for the treatment of the symptoms did
the diseases leave a dope
if the girl it in what way wanna take a
pill
Sanomat four times a day your pics 3
generally that kiss me under control
and work around that killed box in Miami
pocket so I remember my medication
medication or are worth worth having
you havin fun fact that there are the
desirable
or near the balloting job yeah after
ballot
do you want to do something or you now
wanna them from Firefly
one of the complications are leave a
dope a therapy lso's
Sanomat therapy is that camp in May
cause abnormal movements we call these
abnormal movements disc I'm easy is
those pages may well benefit from
surgery deep brain stimulation
that the terminal recommended so gently
in I was scandal it I was scared outta
my mind
so I decided
bad though the third really and whatever
happens happens
the mean girl menso
unbelievable I mean it was like a
different person
deep brain stimulation or DBS
is essentially a pacemaker but instead
of going to the heart
it goes to the brain and were able to
affect the activity in a certain part
the brain
that is involved in the generation the
symptoms of Parkinson's disease
and we can make some other symptoms of
Parkinson's better by using this
technique
I don't fall anymore an own
I've been went on vacation the summer
to Memphis Tennessee
there is such a thing as waiting too
long
to do surgery if the a patient's
symptoms have progressed to the point
where medications are no longer affected
at all
it means that surgery will be no longer
a factor my Walkman right now
it's stored in the garage collecting
best
after DBS a patient still has
Parkinson's
their parkinson's will continue to
progress despite the fact that they're
being stimulated
and so it's not a disease altering
treatment there is
emerging research that supports the idea
that
an active lifestyle may forestall on
progression of Parkinson's disease it
also gives
the patient a sense that they are doing
something
to fight their disease have taken up
yoga
because the stretching the things that
provide
some summer really I can walk into your
with to play in a
trailing arm and I'll even I'm walking
normally TV go do more often
her I strongly counsel patience
to develop an exercise routine that he
is sacred
that his one of their priorities in any
day
cleaning up yeah I think exercise
is probably when is the number one
things people can do
it helps cognition it helps generate new
stem cells and neurons in the brain
it also helps people's arm movement
issues as well
I have a blog it'd from it's getting
seven hundred thousand hits
and so it's interesting to me how many
people read about it but I find that
really therapeutic to
Gillard from my feeling that but it also
allows my friends to look at it and not
have to
here for me but know how I'm feeling
rationally
becomes for troop leader well
about four years after I I and a support
group
you know the fact that PC worried now to
support me
and my problems that it means a lot
we have an online support group as a
Facebook thing it's about
18 women who are are I guess the onset
Parkinson's they're all kinda
the one rule is you have to try to
remain positive and we trying to feed
off each other's negative things but
that's really helped me out a lot
to know them alone I wish God would save
this can be a bad day so beware
it just doesn't happen that way hi it
all of a sudden I need someone to help
me do something or just to be nice to me
and this is this is
it's a surprise the unknown
is very difficult for me I'm
and so i i accept kind and I embrace it
I needed I want people to
helping
I think UCSF is unique in that its
general mission really supports the
mission at the Parkinson center
we do outreach we do teaching were
involved in teaching residents and
fellows
we have experts in the field and these
experts actually see the patience
we have a multidisciplinary experts as
well
which bring their knowledge base to air
treatment of patients
and we have some very exciting
cutting-edge research
into the green is the metformin blue is
the kitchen I months a came to terms
with it that's when I
decided I'm gonna go to UC with date me
know what's going on
apparently cutting edge and I want to be
part of that there are many clinical
trials a potential
that therapeutic agents underway
and if patients want to take part in
these trials only have to contact us
my group has been working over the years
in trying three deliver drugs directly
to the brain
using your surgical technology so using
this technology now to the word
the well victors I i want to talk I'll
try here
you see if and I had a a
gene transfer therapy where were they
injected the gene into bar I brain
the stimulated into produce lead over me
and a it produced the result
I'm happy I did the because they gave me
a chance to
contribute something to try it even
though it isn't
they are here there may be another step
in learning
more about the and embittered
perfect people if Justin Rose Hall
Council being able to
onto the divers absences to the brain
that can rejuvenate
the cells or give rise to the cells
which
are within the brain and is a stem cells
that may be able to actually pick up the
function of the
new round it has died and his ultimate
goal
and I don't think I'm imagining things
and we have prove
home the design actually can take place
because parkinson's is within a small
area in the brain it's a good candidate
for stem cell research there are many
fundamental questions that need to be
answered before
stem cell therapy could be brought into
the clinically
part of that is we have to be cautious
and
so the stakes are high I mean that could
really be
a credibly good news for
for a patient with Parkinson's disease
I'm open to anything
I'll do anything anything that is coming
down any kinda
new medication please put me on it
you know and one of them in fact is
being really negative for me
really exacerbated the symptoms
but I don't care because I'd I if if
it's out there I wanna find it
said
goes time in my life to see other night
them the word came on you know I'm so
happy these days
wife is very good you know even know
North
her cup tits thing
unit expect enter into industry
it is they have so much hope in a lake
really
Chile believe they'll finally care and
that conveyed to me is a
message status key thing I'm me
believing in for
strong medicine
it's possible to live without confound
and feel am a normal I and that pic
Antonio
yourself in your home in the family I
think what I would like other people to
do with to
to get involved includes to become
militant about it didn't try to find a
way to
to solve this problem parkinson's will
probably be
the first neurodegenerative disorder for
which we find a cure
because it's very discreet a
and compared to the other
neurodegenerative disorders we know
quite a bit about it this is a disease
for which has
every reason to be optimistic there are
many different
therapeutic developments being explored
that I think hold
a great promise for the future that good
things
that is you can't fight this
you can resist I'm not saying Kim's
I have not been able to stop it someone
can tell me how to stop it
please tell me stopper I feel is is
positive mental attitude
believing that that
things are going to get better I'm I
believe
that they're gonna find a cure for this
thing
and and this will not be the way that I
can
sold those kind of hope you know
and seen wonderful thing
like success on my comp
my children succeed him
my wife happy
the singer's user incredible things and
if I can just keep eyes on that
rather than the original diagnosis I can
make
it
said
old
school
cool up
in